[Music]
as we start designing the next Mass
Effect game we start by asking fans what
they want you know what Mass Effect
means to them one of the things that
fans have told us most about what they
want in the next Mass Effect game is to
go somewhere new and to move forward new
places new characters new people to fall
in love with we're taking you to a whole
new region of space this world is so
vast that you can just kind of continue
on to the horizon there's more more
experience for the player to joy they
can plan it across the other side of the
galaxy and fly there and see what we
will discover imagine we can do now with
the power of new console is an amazing
soft room
it all looks fantastic we've never seen
these characters this real before we
think fans of the series are going to be
surprised at just how far we're going
while my trail studio is working on the
next Mass Effect game our team here in
Edmonton is developing a completely new
IP it's a chance to have clean sheet
designs start from most fundamental
principles you can have we want to take
on very contemporary stories and yet we
want to build a world that is as big and
as imaginative as everything we've done
before starts off with baby steps what
are the environments
what are cities like what are characters
like so we're trying to build a
fictional world that feels real and is
alive and is constantly changing this is
what the world is doing right now come
and play at Bioware we're building
worlds and journeys for the next
generation how far can we go with these
new games wait and see
[Applause]
[Music]